-Performing "Kind Of Girl"
from their upcoming
self-titled album,
give it up for Muna!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I'm the kind of girl ♪
♪ Who takes things
a little too far ♪
♪ Presses a little too hard ♪
♪ That's why you left a mark ♪
♪ And I'm the kind of girl ♪
♪ Who wants everything
she can't get ♪
♪ Leaving alone and yet ♪
♪ Somehow still leaving a mess,
but ♪
♪ I'm a girl who's learning ♪
♪ Everything I say
isn't definitive ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm not some kind of
minor trope ♪
♪ Who's never gonna change,
that's so, derivative ♪
♪♪
♪ I could get up tomorrow ♪
♪ Talk to myself real gentle ♪
♪ Work in the garden ♪
♪♪
♪ Go out and meet somebody ♪
♪ Who actually likes me for me ♪
♪ And this time, I'll let them ♪
♪♪
♪ Yeah, I like telling stories ♪
♪ But I don't have to write them
in ink ♪
♪ I could still change the end ♪
♪ At least I'm the kind
of girl ♪
♪ I'm the kind of girl who
thinks I can ♪
♪♪
♪ The kind of girl who thinks
I can ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm the kind of girl ♪
♪ Who's likely to drive you
insane ♪
♪ Restless, forever untamed ♪
♪ A little in love with
the pain, but ♪
♪ I'm the kind of girl ♪
♪ Who owns up to all
of my faults ♪
♪ Who's learning to laugh at 'em
all ♪
♪ Like I'm not a problem to
solve ♪
♪ I'm a girl who's blowing on
a dandelion ♪
♪ Thinking how the winds could
change at any given time ♪
♪ I could get up tomorrow ♪
♪ Talk to myself real gentle ♪
♪ Work in the garden ♪
♪♪
♪ Go out and meet somebody ♪
♪ Who actually likes me for me ♪
♪ And this time, I'll let them ♪
♪ Ooh, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, I like telling stories ♪
♪ But I don't have to write them
in ink ♪
♪ I could still change the end ♪
♪ At least I'm the kind
of girl ♪
♪ I'm the kind of girl who
thinks I can ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh,
mm-hm ♪
♪ The kind of girl who thinks
I can ♪
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh,
mm-hm ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh,
mm-hm ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh,
mm-hm ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]